mesdames et messieurs bienvenue sur
Antenne 2 le c'est mignon animateur que
je suis a pour plaisir de recevoir sur
ce plateau télévisé lâcher qui nous
regarde de cette magnifique province
qu'on adore tant mais également la jeune
Clara non moins c'est mignon bien sûr le
trots c'est toujours la façon dont les
trots donc un filtré des grands
mouvements ou des syndics monsieur vous
êtes d'accord
il suffit pour les trots on les
connaissait pas les chefs même encore il
faut aller lire des livres sur les
années 50 pour trouver les noms des
responsables c'est exactement le système
trots qui est à l'oeuvre regardez comme
ça lui va bien
[Musique]
et je ne peux pas enlever mon casque
donc on va faire toute l'expertise avec
ce masque étrange de Dark Vador un des
personnages les plus méchants de
l'histoire du cinéma mondial alors
l'infiltration des prises dans le
mouvement n'est pas impossible elle
n'est pas à ce jour à l'heure Gérard je
pense si vous me permettez que c'est un
logiciel qui est plus tard
oui parce qu'à l'époque les animateurs
de télévision parler avec ce ton et avec
ce phrasé et puis également le côté
nasia on ne sait pas pourquoi revenons à
la couleur c'est quand même vachement
mieux
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début
vous n'êtes pas concerné par les
revendications
[Musique]
sauf que cette fois-ci la facture risque
d'être plus élevée et tourner plutôt
autour de 30 millions la journée de
grève la raison et bien c'est le
processus de dédommagement offert aux
usagers qui est nettement plus
avantageux que d'habitude le Bruel des
paroles et paroles et paroles vite de
sens
impossible de savoir si le Nouvel An
sera épargné car le mouvement est
difficile à contrôler et imprévisible
c'est des revendications très
catégorielles et en plus très individuel
donc chacun apporte sa demande donc
c'est très compliqué à gérer et
déterminer une position commune beau
pays mais je voudrais qu'on écoute
d'abord monsieur farandou il était sur
RTL ce matin PDG de la SNCF
on ne l'entend pas monsieur farrandou
donc je pense que nous avons un souci
avec Monsieur farrandou d'un autre côté
j'ai l'impression que les grévistes ne
l'entendent pas non plus donc c'est
finalement nous avons voulu
éditorialement mettre en place cette
nonne écoute alors le trajet initial
c'était Lyon Rennes Rennes Quimper et
finalement ça se transforme en lion
Paris Le Mans Le Mans Rennes et Rennes
Quimper voilà 14 heures de trajet pour
au lieu de 7
bavé comme ça les familles et tout
avec le covid tout ce qu'il y a et tout
on peut pas se comporter comme ça ils
sont quand même privilégiés il faut pas
qu'ils oublient ça quand même ces
gens-là habituellement en Ukraine la
plupart des orthodoxes suivent le
calendrier russe et faites Noël le 7
janvier mais cette famille de ni pro a
choisi de le célébrer le 25 décembre
[Musique]
oh c'est mignon
maintenant le principal c'est de fêter
Noël avec le rock
de supprimer
effacer tout ce qui nous ramène
c'est tout ce qui nous relie à la Russie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans cette ville de l'est du pays les
habitants ont voté cette année pas de
décoration pas de sapin l'argent
économisé ira à l'armée la guerre c'est
la guerre ici on a pas de sapin mais
là-bas dans les tranchées il meurt de
froid nous sommes d'accord de ne pas
avoir de sapin nous sommes patients nous
attendrons la victoire et après la
victoire nous aurons un sapin
mais attention à ne pas tomber dedans
quand on est petit sinon vous risquez de
devenir comme Sarah qui n'écoute plus
que ça
épuisement de la famille à partir du
moment où je suis dans une pièce je mets
des chansons de Noël même au travail il
me déteste et il met des écouteurs ça va
de Tino Rossi à Mariah Carey ou quoi
il y a des choses qu'on peut enfiler
mais plus retirer c'est marrant c'est
bizarre dans un sens ça marche
la tototte qui va avec ça c'est de la
tototte de compétition ça alors la
cocotte c'est quand je suis pas content
et je pleure voilà
[Musique]
[Rires]